rousseau opens his 1762 book
the social contract with the following
statement
man is born free and everywhere he's in
chains
so you talk about freedom and
sovereignty quite a bit
what do these ideas mean to you the idea
of sovereignty
freedom and sovereignty um i think
they're very closely related
let's start just focusing on sovereignty
which is a word i don't think we talk
about enough
um and the general definition of that i
would give is the authority to act
as you see fit um
and it's a word that's etymologically
associated with words like monarchy
money rain so historically
it's referred to whatever the locus of
supreme power is
in the sphere of human action so whether
if you go
like back into ancient egypt the pharaoh
had absolute sovereignty and everyone
else was pretty much
operating according to his interests you
fast forward to
today modern western democracy we have
um more decentralized sovereignty and
that we all get to go vote and elect
officials that make decisions on our
behalf
so the the theme of sovereignty across
history is that it's been gradually
decentralizing across our different
models of socioeconomics and
it's largely you could say it's rooted
heavily
in the money i would argue which is
something we'll get a lot into here
where
if you have money you have the authority
to act as you see fit in the world
and even in our current political sphere
if you have enough money you can
actually shape reshape the rules right
you can reshape laws you can lobby
congress
um if you're in a certain
situation like many billionaires you can
negotiate your own tax treaty
such that you can get favorable tax
treatment with certain jurisdictions in
the world
so this concept of of sovereignty um
which today we call it's
common to call states or nation-states
or governments sovereign
meaning that they have power over people
um
but as i argue in a lot of my writing i
actually think that sovereignty inheres
within the individual
and that we each have our own
interiorized space of choice
which is something like viktor frankl
called the final human freedom
and that we no matter what our
circumstances are no matter what
uh exogenous situation we face we always
have this endogenous power
to choose how we respond to it that's
one of my favorite books is uh man
search for meaning
maybe you can break that apart a little
bit
so you've kind of spoken about
sovereignty as uh
closely linked to power but is there
something about your own mind
being able to achieve sovereignty
no matter what the monetary system is no
matter what who has the control over
centralized power the money or whatever
the mechanisms of
uh sovereignty and the societal level
you as an individual
isn't ultimately all boiled down to what
you can do with your mind
how you see the world yeah yeah i agree
and as we get a little bit deeper into
this uh you i think we'll come to see
money as an extension of your mind
so there's a feedback between money and
mind for instance you think in dollars
today
i almost guarantee it most of us do here
in the us
um and it's it's a tool right it's a
tool we're using to decomplexify the
world around us
to deal with it to understand
the sacrifices and successes across an
entire history of economic transactions
we can boil that all down to the price
so it's data compression and if you can
change if there's a central body or
central governance mechanism that can
manipulate that money it can have an
impact on your mind
for instance today so i agree with you
in the first hand say that
i do believe in free will i do believe
in
individual autonomy but i also think
that
there are certain devices and powers in
the world around us that can actually
influence how we think
and it's fascinating to think about the
fact that money might be
actually deeply integrated into the way
we think and
into our mind like this is uh you think
about what are the core aspects of the
human mind
what influences cognition the way you
reason about the world
you have the chomsky like language is at
the core of everything
but you're kind of placing money
as pretty close to the core of what it
means to be
an intelligent reasoning human i think
money is a direct derivation of action
and speech
actually it's another expression of the
logos
if we even think of what it means to
think
is that we are generating two different
courses of action
potential courses of action and we're
populating them with avatars right maybe
ourselves or others
and then we're comparing how we may act
in each situation and what we think the
result would be so
actually it's comparison basically it's
comparison and contrasting of possible
courses of action and
that's the same thing with words
themselves like
you know most words the uh
the vast majority of words only have
meaning in relationship to other words
right it's all contextual
definitions of a word or more words now
people have argued
with me about this because there is a
first word right where you pick up rock
and say rock
but most other words and much uh in in
higher abstraction tend to be
relative and what's funny about
action and speech and this gets i got
into a bit of this in our paper here is
it
it's linked to evolutionary biology and
that once
human beings adopted upright stance
we freed our hands we no longer needed
our hands for locomotion
so we started to evolve more dexterity
and notably we have opposable thumb so
this gives us an ability to manipulate
and particularize the environment in a
way that most other animals cannot
and what's interesting about this is
that as we gain this ability to
manipulate natural resources and you
know count
point pointing was a big deal and that
we could indicate
prey or or items that are far off
distance and we could organize ourselves
[Music]
we at the same time we co-evolved this
fine musculature
in the face and tongue so it's as if
speech developed co-evolved really with
our dexterity
and as a natural extension of that
came us making tools right we started to
create things to
better satisfy our wants over time and
the most tradable tool in any society or
the most tradable thing is money
so i really i argue that action
and speech are quintessential modes of
self-sovereign expression
and that money is just sort of a tech
layer we put right on top of that
and that it's a natural derivation of
action and speech
you